what angle whose tangent is is half is
0.46 radians so we're saying the D the
tangent right over here is so the
tangent so we're let me write this down
so we're saying that the tangent 0.46
radians is equal to 1/2 and another way
of thinking about the tangent of an
angle is that's the slope of that angles
terminal ray so it's the slope of this
ray right over here then yeah that's
that make sense that that slope is about
1/2 now what other angles have a have a
tangent of 1/2 so let's look at these
choices so this is our original angle
0.46 radians plus PI over 2 if you think
in degrees pi is 180 PI over 2 is 90
degrees so this one this one actually
let me do it in a color you're more
likely to see this one is going to look
like this it's going to look like this
where this is an angle of PI over 2 and
just eyeballing you immediately see that
the slope of this ray is very different
than the slope of this ray right over
here in fact they look like in fact they
are they are perpendicular because they
have an angle of PI over 2 between them
but they're definitely not going to have
the same tangent so they're not going to
have the same Tanit they don't have the
same slope now it's think about PI minus
0.46 so that's essentially pi is going
along the positive x axis if you go all
the way around or halfway around you're
at PI radians then we're going to
subtract 0.46 so it's going to look it's
going to look something like this it's
going to look something like that where
this is 0.46 that we have subtracted
another way to think about it if we take
our original terminal array and we flip
it over the y-axis we get to this
terminal ray right over here and you
could immediately see that the slope of
the terminal ray is not the same as the
slope of this one of our first one our
original in fact they look like they
look like the negatives of each other so
we could rule that one out as well
0.46 plus PI or PI plus 0.46 so that's
going to take us that's going to take a
few if you add PI to this you're
essentially going halfway around the
unit circle and you're getting to a
point
that is or you're forming array that is
collinear with the original array so
that's that angle right over here so PI
plus 0.46 is this entire angle right
over there and when you just look at
this ray you see it's collinear it's
going to have the exact same slope as
the terminal ray for 0.46 radians so
just that tells you that the tangent is
going to be the same so I could check
that there and in previous videos when
we explore the symmetries of the tangent
function we in fact saw that that if you
took an angle and you add PI to it
you're going to have the same tangent
and if you want to dig a little bit
deeper I encourage you to look at that
video on the symmetries of unit circle
symmetries for the tangent function so
let's look at these other choices - pi -
is 0.46 so 2 pi if this if this is 0
degrees - pi gets you back to gets you
back to the positive x-axis and then
you're going to subtract 0.46 so that's
going to be this angle right over here
and that looks like it has the negative
slope of this original ray right up here
so these aren't going to have the same
tangent not the same tangent now this
one you're taking 0.46 and you're adding
two pi so you're taking 0.46 0.46 and
then you're adding two pi which
essentially is just going around the
unit circle once and you get to the
exact same point so you add 2 pi to any
angle measure you're going to not only
have the same tan Val tangent value
going to the same sine value cosine
value because you're essentially going
back around to the exact same angle when
you add 2 pi so this is definitely this
is definitely also going to be true